the rage is a brand new IP created by
its software if you don't know its
software we invented the first person
John right so we know from first
shooters rage is much different than
Jude quake for weapons time at its core
though it's still you know like a
running gun game but we have all these
other aspects to it that make it more
than just a corridor shooter
we have vehicle combat we have vehicle
racing we have a deep story we have like
many colorful characters that you you
interact with it really is epic
single-player experience so let's say
the sheriff gives you a mission you know
he wants you to go head off and take out
a group of bandits that are causing
trouble to eventually make it to your
destination you're in a mission area and
once you enter those areas that you know
you know these are these on foot
first-person action zones that maybe
them in famous our character progression
really centers around what you have you
know so every new environment that we
create for the player we want to give
them something new to play with but you
know it may be a new weapon or new ammo
type or new engineering item so your
character doesn't progress you know
through just a numeric levels you know
cuz that's boring it really your
character progresses through all the
stuff you can do your arsenal of weapons
and engineering items and of course your
cool vehicles it's not your kind of
classic open-world game
and hence a as a story it has a
progression you know as game players we
hate to get lost so enraged you always
know where you need to go you can just
go back to your your mission page and
you can see you know what you need to do
but we also have many opportunities for
people to explore the world through some
side missions maybe some extra races you
know and if those are optional but if
you decide to do those the world is
rewarding you know for you so it's more
really than just a wedding
so raid will be available for all the
main platforms to PC the ps3 and the 360
and it will be available in September of
this year